an england team backed by
impassioned home support at london's
wembley stadium
an italian side on a mission to take the
european championship trophy
back to rome
[Music]
england couldn't have dreamt of making a
better start
here
luke shaw putting his country ahead in
just the second minute
quite a time for him to score his first
international goal
the fastest ever in a euro final a
little
half full as it turns out
unbeaten in their last 33 games italy
wrestled their way back into contention
federico chiesa
going close and that's the sharpest
trust from the italians so far
the second half began with raheem
sterling taking a tumble in the italian
box
the referee deciding to wave england
away rather than point at the penalty
spot
the two have accused him of diving
already tonight
[Applause]
italy then began to take control of the
game
leonardo bonucci converting that
pressure into a deserved equaliser
[Applause]
with england struggling to escape the
grasp of their opponents
the match headed into extra time
[Applause]
the impact of an energy sapping night
and tournament was becoming evident
this final would be decided in a penalty
shootout
neither team looked assured from the
spots
[Applause]
[Music]
but it was english teenager boko saka
who missed the decisive kick
it meant italy could celebrate their
first european title since
1968.
a team that didn't qualify for the last
world cup will soon be turning their
focus to a similar success
at next year's finals in qatar
andy richardson al jazeera